vigésima reunión del Consejo de
Seguridad de la ONU en lo que va de año
siempre con un mismo tema Ucrania
el orden internacional que hemos logrado
Aquí está siendo destrozado ante
nuestros ojos
no podemos dejar no dejaremos que el
presidente salga con la suya una sesión
con ánimos caldeados tras las recientes
amenazas nucleares veladas de Vladimir
Putin en la que occidente ratificó su
apoyo
un hombre eligió esta guerra un hombre
puede terminarla porque si Rusia deja de
luchar la guerra termina
Ucrania deja de luchar Ucrania termina
al tiempo que el discurso ruso escaló su
canciller señaló que la ayuda
internacional recibida por Ucrania
implica occidente en el conflicto
lo están afirmando claramente prolongar
la lucha del mayor tiempo posible a
pesar de las víctimas y la destrucción
con el fin de desgastar y debilitar a
Rusia
esa política significa la participación
directa de occidente en el conflicto y
los convierte en parte del conflicto
también dejó Clara la posición del
kremlin Respecto a los organismos
internacionales
no tenemos confianza en el trabajo de
este organismo todo lo que ha dicho hoy
simplemente confirma que la decisión de
llevar a cabo la operación militar
especial era Inevitable al terminar su
intervención abandonó la sala situación
que no pasó por alto por el ministro de
exteriores de Ucrania
también observé hoy que los diplomáticos
rusos huyen casi también como los
soldados rusos en en el secretario
general de la ONU Antonio Gutiérrez
calificó de inaceptable la posibilidad
de una escalada nuclear china llamó al
diálogo y el fiscal de la corte Karim
Khan afirmó que existen motivos
razonables para creer que se han
cometido varios delitos que se pueden
enmarcar dentro de la jurisdicción del
organismo encargado de juzgar crímenes
de guerra de lesa humanidad y de
genocidio